Despite being the fastest man alive, Barry
Allen a.k.a.
The Flash, played by Grant Gustin, was unable
to outrun the coronavirus in 2020.
Season 6 of the CW series was cut short due
to the cast and crew being unable to finish
filming the final few episodes, forcing episode
19 to become the makeshift season finale.
It functioned as an effective cliffhanger,
considering Iris West mysteriously vanished.
That was back in May of 2020, and fans have
been waiting with bated breath to discover
her fate.
Fortunately, the season's endgame became a
little clearer with the return of The Flash
on March 2nd, 2021.
While we've technically now jumped to season
7 of the series, the first episode picks up
right where season 6 episode 19 left off,
so it won't be long until we get the thrilling
conclusion of Flash going toe-to-toe with
Mirror Master, played by Efrat Dor.
When that battle does commence, however, Team
Flash will be short one member.
Season 7 didn't waste any time raising the
stakes, and it did so in a pretty intense
fashion by offing someone The Flash fans have
been well acquainted with over the last few
years.
Suffice to say, plenty of viewers were upset
by the death — especially coming on the
heels of Green Arrow's recent departure from
the franchise he launched.
At least this character said goodbye to The
Flash with a fitting tribute.
“For the flash to run again, Nash Wells
must die.”
Tom Cavanagh’s character, Harrison Wells,
has gone through an interesting progression
throughout the first six seasons of The Flash.
He starts off as your average mentor-turned-villain-in-disguise
before returning to the show via the multiverse.
Most recently, the Council of Wells found
themselves within the head of the only remaining
physical version of Wells, who goes by Nash
after the "Crisis on Infinite Earths" event.
In season 7, episode 1, Barry loses his access
to the Speed Force, and the only way he can
get it back is for Nash, and thereby all of
the Harrison Wellses in the multiverse, to
die.
“How can I be the Flash without a Wells
on this team?”
Barry pleads with Nash not to go through with
it, but Nash makes the ultimate sacrifice
play so that Flash has a chance of stopping
Mirror Master.
“You’ve Always been the Flash…
You always will be…
With or with or without me.”
Cavanagh has been with the series since the
very beginning.
He may have embodied different versions of
the same character, but his presence was practically
always a given.
It looks like that could change for the future
of The Flash, and fans have been pretty emotional
about the loss.
After all, every version of Wells across every
dimension supposedly died, so it really seems
like this is the end of his tenure on the
series.
One fan gave the character a proper tribute
by writing,
"For six seasons Tom [Cavanagh] was one of
the best parts of this show.
We will always have the Wells goodbye parade."
Another Twitter user points out that everything
came full circle with his demise:
"It's funny how a version of Harrison Wells
was responsible for Barry getting his powers
and now another version of Harrison Wells
made sure that Barry kept his powers."
Some other comments directed toward Wells
include:
"I was not prepared for how much of an emotional
roller coaster this episode would be"
Another user praised Cavanagh, writing:
"Tom Cavanagh as the multiple Harrison Wells
has always been Emmys worthy."
The Flash just won't be the same without some
version of Harrison Wells around ... so is
it possible he could come back?
Death is rarely the end in comic book properties.
Superman, Batman, and even the other Flash,
Wally West, all bit the dust in the comics
only to be resurrected shortly thereafter.
Considering multiple versions of Harrison
Wells have already died on the show, it's
understandable some fans may be suspicious
of the sacrifice.
One fan speculated,
"As much as I feel like they've overplayed
the whole multiple Harrison Wells storyline,
I don't think they'll just kill him off."
These kinds of fans have good reason not to
feel too down in the dumps yet, as The Flash
showrunner since season 6, Eric Wallace, has
pretty much confirmed actor Tom Cavanagh will
return in some capacity in the future.
He told TV Insider,
"Everybody unhappy that their favorite Wells
character or characters is dead, never to
be seen, won't have long to wait because Tom
Cavanagh is still a part of this show."
He goes on to hint how it, quote, "won't take
very long for [his] return in an unexpected
new way."
There you have it; Harrison Wells isn't gone
for good quite yet.
It remains to be seen how "unexpected" his
return ends up being.
After all, this is a character we've seen
as a French detective, a cyborg, and a wizard,
so it will take a lot to truly surprise Flash
fans at this point.
With the multiverse at its disposal, the show
can be as creative as it needs to be to keep
an actor as great as Cavanagh onboard.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superhero shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.